[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer sehr
luftige ausgabe
es geht in den nächsten minuten um alles
was über uns ist nämlich den
österreichischen luftraum aber
eigentlich spannend ist was hier
passiert herzlich willkommen in zeltweg
in der steiermark
ich gehe da drüben jetzt mal in den
handel und wird auch einen kommandanten
treffen
hallo schöne wird willkommen im flieger
centric dankeschön und willkommen im
überwachungsstaat der luftraum hat sehr
wohl grenzen und gesetzt das restliche
bundesheer mit der luftraumüberwachung
die luft kommt im wachen ist er eine der
hauptaufgaben der österreichischen
luftstreitkräfte passive
luftraumüberwachung bekannt als die gold
habe ist ja über ganz österreich
verstreut mit ladestationen stationär
mobil aber die aktive komponente mit dem
haupt system eurofighter befindet sich
in sexy finden hier die tücken der a40
das flugzeug zu 7
das 105 und das ziel jedes tipp belaufen
sich auf wetter zufrieden ich damals
selber fliegen
das wird sicher möglich sein nach einem
gewissen training die militärpiloten
ausbildung die es ja ein sehr langer weg
ja ich hätte ich habe heute habe ich
einen relativ hohen bedarf an die klappe
wochen nachwuchs schauen was ist meine
anteile an dich ich sage mal an am
anfang herzlich willkommen
deine fitness auch ausreicht um bei uns
mitzufahren
die körperlichen anfang ein bisschen
schon bitte sehr natürlich ordentlich
aber ich bin zuversichtlich dass du das
schaffst lehmann ihr habt da drinnen
alles was spaß macht auch schmecken
genauso spaß macht kann er nicht
versprechen aber auf jeden fall einen
coach tätig einweisen
ich übergebe ich jetzt zum coach
probiert
genauso wie man das vorgestellt
[Musik]
ja nichts gehört
[Applaus]
wie dem auch sei
unter
also das ist unser space mit denen du
die körperspannung hält also dich dann
wieder stabilisieren
[Musik]
eigentlich ist das einzige fitness
gleich zu hause bleiben aus
er war super
das war nicht die beste ich glaube ich
habe immer schon lange
der spaß
lasst den schwarzwald
[Musik]
der coach hat mir erzählt du bist viel
zu fliegen so nett von ihm der ganze
sport gestanden
und jetzt kommen zur flugrichtung hatte
dazu schon besonderes anliegen
das ist nicht nur hinter hosen ja auch
liebevoll die speed team genannt
das ist die anti die hose die braucht
auf jeden fall jetzt einfach die
zentrifugalkräfte auf die wirken und wie
das lohne der hose bewusstlos werden was
macht die hose die plastik auf um das
blut in den beinen abzusperren
damit wir so verhindert werden dass du
eben die bucht muss jetzt zusätzlich
kann man wirklich den helm mit
sauerstoffmaske
sie ist kopfhörer und mikrofon
integriert kann einmalig was nehmen wir
haben alles vorbereitet für dich damit
alles was das fliegen brauchst die
feuerfeste unterwäsche okay natürlich
muss die piloten aufzeichnen die noten
oberen piloten euro bereit
wir haben es schon die lage ist mit
deinem namen ordentliche flieger stiefel
die engel sitzen wird um die hohe
belastung ein gegendruck in der belle zu
geben feuerwehr ist die hardtschule wird
und hoffentlich ist es nicht benötigen
wie kommst du denn es gibt es mehr
erstes website hat das ist heute jeder
mit
außer dem piloten drei auf mich zu
deutlich transport deutlich gezeigt wir
haben die ausgestattet ist selbst hast
du deine luft auf der schönen flug geht
es ja natürlich kommt sie mit ganz
wichtig
[Musik]
nein gesagt
endlich
[Musik]
robert herzlich willkommen im
wartungsbereich ihr heute schon eine
ganz wichtige satz gesagt wenn es
alleine im cockpit bist bist mir alleine
weil es können haben sich die menschen
dazu sagen hier ist ein teil davon und
zwar die luftfahrzeuge instandsetzung
wir haben luft fahrzeugtechnik bilden
wir aus derzeit 19 mädels und burschen
wir haben auch dazu elektronik
kommunikations electric und
betriebsmittel logistik ist jetzt zum
beispiel sofort auf den ersten blick das
paar an oberflächen diese vollkommen
richtig behaupten das neue triebwerk das
wird in den nächsten stunden und tagen
eingebaut das heißt hochzeit wenn der
motor wieder in den menschen komplett
eingelassen ist es ja auch krieg das
machen hatte das ist ein moment erstmal
man zu dritt zu viert man das zusammen
machen wir werden das ist unser
täglicher job immer sagen man sieht dass
ich gar nicht so genau und jetzt kriegst
das sommergeschäft zurück ja ja das
heißt das ist der protest schon vor
höheren preisen als mir preisverfalls
motor aus und davon dass man vorher noch
funktioniert sagte mir ich weiß dass
fahrer aus
das ist jetzt herausgefahren als sein
vater
[Musik]
so werde am heutigen nachmittag super
gestorben wir würden sich jederzeit als
lehrling bei uns aufnehmen
danke für so passiert es bei dir danke
[Musik]
ich habe eine großartige sind
das angebot
[Musik]
am ende ein kamerateam das wetter im
hintergrund dass wir alle anderen worten
wird darauf wie oft gemeldet worden wie
es entgangen und
robert ich darf dich begrüßen wir in der
halle 1 wir sind hier im für die
basismaterial der haltung saab 105
zuständig ich stell mir das jetzt leider
schwierig voran düsenjet
auseinanderbauen wieder zu bauen
es ist eigentlich man muss nur die
zusammenhänge verstehen weil das bei mir
meistens ist ja aber es wird nichts
passieren
vielleicht glaubt dass man trotzdem gern
selber wieder anschauen
[Musik]
im
ja
[Musik]
danke danke
die ware power hat der tower oder
allerdings eine richtung keiner so
werden beim job ist es unter anderem auf
jede art von ernstfall vorbereitet das 1
die verletzungen des österreichischen
luftraums wäre so ein ernstfall
das ist so wir haben hier den aktiven
teil der luftwaffe spricht der
alarmrotte mit unseren eurofightern und
auf einmal bekommt sie die meldung okay
es ist soll zu einem alarm statt
der eurofighter kommen wird das selber
nicht gewusst aber es gibt natürlich
jemanden der andauernd auf uns aufpassen
es ist nicht so wie bei der name
eingrenzen dass da irgendwo posten sitzt
denkt sie und hinter dem augenblick wo
dein fahrzeug kommt er über die bürger
kommt was man sagt ja was ist dort genau
dort sitzt der passive teil unserer
luftraumüberwachung die luftbeobachtung
dh erkennen hier ein problem frühzeitig
lösen die einen alarm starter aus die
piloten besetzen ihre flieger wir für
nebenbei koordinationsteam durch damit
dieser flug auch sicher stattfinden kann
das müssten zivile flüge umgeleitet
werden und ausweichen
es gibt sondern priorität alpha flug das
heißt er bricht alle regeln ok dann geht
das ganze und ich habe gesehen
[Musik]
was haben wir dann das ist der
photonischen simulator okay
der simulator ist für uns natürlich in
der ausbildung raum zur wesentliches
tool ganze kuppel in der bringen
so soll die gesamte umgehen
projiziert hier dazu wir haben sowohl am
simulator in wirklichkeit natürlich so
etwas zu trainieren aber es ist viel
wichtiger das ganze in friedberg zu
machen können weil eben die reale
belastung die umgebung mit dass aus
stoffmaske unterschiede alles was man
verspürt und gleichzeitig geistig
flexibel zu bleiben
taktisch zu arbeiten die funken
gleichzeitig dass die herausforderung
machen
[Musik]
oma
oder gerollt
als beifahrer martins recht vielleicht
sollte man ansetzen
ich glaube es ist zeit dass die nationen
sind seit der ablöse ist da so sitzt im
cockpit vom eurofighter
wir sind startbereit
heute zum ziel als steighilfe
weiterziehen
perfekt 3000 fuß bereits wieder verfängt
in deutschland
robert liegt über schals und jetzt
kommst wieder kurven zum flughafen
das hilft mir leisten auszurichten das
leben als haus der bösen geister neben
wieder an wenn ich dann in robert
altmans diese leistung noch geben
und heraus und in die menschen hier
perfekt leute den europa gedanken hätte
ich nicht da bin ich schon
richtig gut ich möchte von der goldhaube
und den rhader systemen die die ganze
zeit darauf aufpassen dass österreich
als sicheres land bleibt bis zu den
frauen und männern die dafür sorgen dass
diese maschinen in die luft gehen wenn
es darauf ankommt den piloten am
steuerknüppel wie unglaublich gut
ausgebildet ihren job machen das jeden
tag des jahres bei tag und nacht
das war eine so unglaubliche erfahrung
ich glaube so so oft ist man und
niederndorf extrem gelitten
das freut uns besonders dass du warst
doch begleitet hat in den letzten tagen
dafür verlierst du ri besonderen touch
bei uns wie du kennen gelernt hast die
grazia taktischen namen du wirst du
centre tenöre einer modestrecke und wir
sondern respekt von einer landung mit
dem eurofighter im simulator das tor
gemacht doch saniert nur den navteq
verdient sondern auch den eurofighter
patch gratuliere freundlich sehr vielen
vielen dank aber wenn ich einen wunsch
äußern darf
wie wird mein job als radiomoderator
nicht gerne aufgeben aber für einen
pilotensitz würde mir das vielleicht
überlegen und die habe eigentlich alles
absolviert das gesundheits check das
sicherheitstraining das fitnesstraining
der simulator sowie
also steht nichts im wege du hast es
verdient sie haben pilotensitz haben
sich gelohnt es jetzt war es dem platz
nehmen was sie kriegen kann jetzt
eigentlich er aber der hier
mm
das ist
so mag
[Musik]